Urban it has citation counts that's six
digit it's more than four one hundred
thirty nine thousand
um and then many more so super excited
to hear what Ilya has to say about llms
in the future take it away okay hi
hi everyone
thank you for the introduction
you know when uh
when Umesh invited me to to attend this
event I got really excited I saw the
holy speak released and I thought great
I'll I'll go and I'll talk about
something
and then I ran into a problem
which is
that a lot of the technical workings
we're doing at open AI actually can talk
about
so I was really racking my head what
could I talk about
right now so as of not too long ago I
switched all my focus to
working on AI alignment
all my research Focus
and we'll have very cool results to show
there but not just yet
so I'm like okay so this would have to
be for the next stop but what would be
good for this stock
and
I came up with something
I'll tell you about some very old
results
that
we had it open AI many years ago back in
2016 even
which really affected the way I think
about unsupervised learning
and I thought I'd share them with you
it is possible that
at this point you'll find them obvious
but maybe not all of them
so there is at least a small chance that
you'll find it interesting
so I want to set the expectations
modestly and hopefully exceed them
so
a theory of unsupervised learning
how can such a thing exist
so okay
before we talk about unsupervised
learning we want to talk about learning
in general
what is learning and why does learning
work at
why should learning work at all and why
should computers be able to learn
and
now we are just used to the fact we take
it for granted that neural networks
learn but but why do they like
mathematically why should they why would
data have regularity
that our machine learning models can
capture
so that's not an obvious question
and one important conceptual advance
that has taken place in machine learning
many years ago
by multiple people
with the discovery and the formalization
of supervised learning
so it goes under the name of back
learning or statistical learning theory
and the nice thing about supervised
learning
is that it gives you a precise
mathematical condition
under which learning must succeed
you're told that if you have some data
from some data distribution
that if you manage to achieve a low
training loss
and the number of your degrees of
freedom
is not is smaller than your
training set
then you will achieve low tester and you
are guaranteed to do so
you have a mathematical condition where
you can say well if
if I did find a function out of my
function class which achieve low
training error
then learning will succeed and you can
say yeah this is a very sensible
mathematical thing
that we can reason about
and that's why supervised learning is
easy
and then you had all these theorems
which I thought were simple you know I
found the Mulligan
you've seen maybe theorems like this if
you have your basically it's like this
is the sort of thing where if you know
it you're going to say oh yeah that
thing and if you don't know it it will
not be possible to explain it in 30
seconds though it is possible to explain
it in five minutes just not 30 seconds
none of this stuff is complicated
and you've got your little proof which
says well if you have some number of
functions in your function class
the probability that your train error
will be far from your test error for at
least one function there is a mass
and the math is simple this is all the
math three lines of math
so three lines of math can prove all of
supervisor
well that's nice
that's very nice
so supervised learning is something that
is well understood
comparatively speaking well understood
we know why it must it must succeed so
we can go forth and collect large
supervised learning data sets and be
completely certain
that models will keep getting better
so
that's that's the story there
and
yeah but forgot to mention a very
important piece of these results the
test distribution and training
distribution need to be the same if
they're the same then your theory of
supervised learning kicks in and works
and will be successful
so conceptually it is trivial
we have an answer for why
supervised learning works why speech
recognition should work by image
categorization should work because they
all reduce to supervised learning which
works which has this mathematical
guarantee
so this is very nice
here I want to make a small side comment
on VC Dimension to those of you who care
about such things there may be a small
subset so if you want to zone out for
the next 30 seconds feel free to do so
so
a lot of writings about
statistical learning theory emphasize
the VC Dimension as a key component
but
the main reason the VC dimension in fact
the only reason the BC Dimension was
invented was to allow us to handle
parameters which have infinite precision
the VC Dimension was invented to handle
Precision like parameters with infinite
Precision so if you have your linear
classifier every parameter is infinite
precision
but then of course in reality
all our floats are finite precision and
their Precision is shrinking so you can
and you could so you have your so the
number of functions that are implemented
by a computer is actually small and you
can reduce it back to the little
this little formula which gives you
pretty much all the best
bounds that you can get from supervised
learning so I find this to be cool I
find this to be appealing because you
have fewer lines of proof
okay
now let's talk about unsupervised
learning
so I claim first of all what is
unsupervised learning what is it
supervised learning is like yeah you've
got your data that says here do this
here do that and you have all this data
you do well in your training error your
training error is low
you'll have more training data than
degrees of freedom in your function
class
parameters but maybe other things too
degrees of freedom at bits
and you say okay I'm super you're super
residentiality will succeed but what is
unsupervised learning what can you say
at all about unsupervised learning
and I'll say that I at least I have not
seen like an exposition of unsupervised
learning which you found satisfying how
to reason about it mathematically we can
reason about it intuitively but can be
reason about it mathematically
and for some context what is the old
dream of unsupervised learning which by
the way this dream has been fulfilled
but it's fulfilled empirically like can
we go just a tiny bit beyond the
empirical results like the idea that you
just look at the images or you just look
at the text without being told what to
do with them and somehow you still
discover the true hidden structure that
exists in the data and somehow it helps
you
why why why should it happen
should it happen
should we expected to happen
you cannot you don't have anything
remotely similar to the supervised
learning guarantee the supervised
learning guarantee says yeah like get
your low training error and you're going
to get your learning it's going to be
great success
unsupervised learning it appears it
appears that it's not this way
you know like people were talking about
it for a long time in the 80s the Bolson
machine was already talking about
self-supervised learning
and I'm super misleading also did not
work at small scale but all that but the
old ideas were there like the noise in
Auto encoder
to those of you who remember remember it
it's like Bert or the diffusion model
within it it's a tiny twist the tiniest
of twists the language models of all
times they also you know generated cool
samples for their time but
they're unsupervised learning
performance was not as impressive as
those of today
but I want to make the case that it is
confusing because it's like
why is it confusing you optimize like
how doesn't suppress learning work you
say okay let's optimize some kind of
reconstruction error or let's optimize
some kind of uh denoising error or like
some kind of
self-supervised learning error you
optimize one objective
right oh yes I just said that but you
care about a different objective
so then doesn't it mean that you have no
reason to expect
that you'll get any kind of good and
supervised learning results so rather
you know you do get them empirically but
like is it going to be like
the level of mystery is quite High I
claim like it seems totally like a
totally inaccessible phenomenon you
optimize one objective but you care
about another objective and yet it helps
how can that be Magic
okay
so yeah
the other thing by the way is that I'm
super well I guess
I'm gonna I'm gonna say something which
is only 90 true
unsupervised learning doesn't you you
could say okay so you just learned the
structure in the input distribution and
it helps you but then
you know what if you're training from
the uniform distribution
then all you're on supervised learning
algorithms will fail
how should you think about that
so what can we say
what can do we need to make assumptions
what kind of assumptions
so I'd like to present potentially
a way of thinking about unsupervised
learning which I think is
I personally find it interesting perhaps
you'll find it interesting too let's
find out
so I want to show you one way of doing
unsupervised learning which is not
necessarily widely known because it
never became the dominant way of doing
that supervised learning but it has the
cool feature that similarly to
supervised learning it has to work
so what kind of
mysterious unsupervised learning
procedure for you not given any labels
to any of your inputs is still
guaranteed to work
distribution matching
so what is distribution matching say
my data I've got X and I've got y
data sources there's no correspondence
between them to two data source data
source exit intercept wise data source y
language one language two
text speech
no correspondence between them
let us look at this Criterion
find the function f
such that the distribution of f of x is
similar to the distribution of Y
it is a constrained on F
and in the case of machine translation
and speech recognition
for example
this constraint might be
meaningful like you could say yeah
if I have like long sentences if if you
tell me that you have a function such
that the distribution you take your
distribution of English sentences
you apply the function f to them and you
get something which is very similar to
the distribution of French sentences you
can say okay
I found the true constraint about f
if the dimensionality of X and the
dimensionality of Y is high enough
that's going to give you a lot of
constraints in fact you might be able to
almost fully recover F from that
information
this is an example of supervised
learning of unsupervised learning where
it is still
guaranteed to work in the same sense
that supervised learning is guaranteed
to work
also substitution ciphers like little
simple encryptions will also fit into
this framework
okay
and so like I I kind of
I ran into this I I've
independently discovered this in 2015.
and I got really fascinated by it
because I thought wow maybe there is
something
meaningful mathematically meaningful
that we can say
about unsupervised learning
and so but let's see this the thing
about this setup is that still it's a
little bit artificial it's still real
machine learning setups aren't like this
and the way we like to think about
unsupervised learning isn't that also
okay now I'll present to you
the meat the meter what I'm going or
what I wanted to say
how
a proposed way to think about
unsupervised learning
that lets you that puts it on par with
supervised learning says okay what is it
doing mathematically how can you be sure
that you're on supervised learning is
good
compression to the rescue
obviously it is well known I shouldn't
say Obviously it is not obvious but it
is well known that compression is
prediction every compressor can be done
to a predictor and vice versa there is a
one-to-one correspondence between all
compressors and all predictors
however
I would argue that for the purpose of
thinking about unsupervised learning
the language of compression offers some
advantages at least for me it did
perhaps it will for you too
so
consider
the following
thought experiment this thought
experiment is the most important slide
say you have two data sets X and Y
in two data sets two files on your big
giant hard disk
and say you have a really great
compression algorithm C which takes data
in
and outputs compressed objects out
say you compress X and Y jointly you
concatenate them you take the two data
sets and you concatenate them and you
feed them to your compressor what will
happen
well let's see what in this particular
an important question is what will a
sufficiently do good compressor will do
my answer is very intuitively it will
use the patterns that exist inside X
to help it compress Y and vice versa
you could make the same Claim about
prediction but somehow it's more
intuitive when you say it about
compression I don't know why there is
but I find it to be the case
so that's a clue
and you can make
an equation like this where you say hey
if your compression is good enough if
it's like a real great compression
compressor it should say that the
compression of your concatenation of
your giant files
should be no worse than the separate
compression of YouTube files
so any additional compression that was
gained by concatenation
is some kind of shared structure that
your compressor noticed
and the better your compressor is the
motion structure it will extract
the Gap is the shared structure or the
algorithmic mutual information
so that's interesting right you can see
what I'm alluding to why is the data of
your supervised task
X is your unsupervised task but suddenly
you have some kind of mathematical
reason
for the information for the patterns in
X to try to help y
notice also how it generalizes
distribution matching
if
we are in the distribution matching case
where you've got your X is language 1
and Y is language two and you're saying
and you know that there exists some
simple function f that transforms one
distribution into the other
surely your compressor if it's good will
notice that and make use of that and
maybe even internally try to recover
this function
foreign
Circle
so how do we formalize it then what will
be the formalization of unsupervised
learning
let's see let's see if I can do it
consider an ml algorithm so here by the
way in what follows I'll be a bit sloppy
and I will use compression and
prediction interchangeably
say you have a machine learning
algorithm a it's an algorithm a and it
tries to compress y
and said has access to X X is file
number one and Y is file number two
you want your machine learning algorithm
your compressor to compress Y and it can
probe X as it says fit the goal is to
compress visible as possible
we can ask ourselves what is our regret
of using this particular algorithm
you'll see what I'm getting at
regret relative to what if I do a good
enough job
if I have like being low regret means
that I've gotten all the help like that
I can possibly get from this unlabeled
data
based on label data has helped me as
much as possible and I don't feel bad
about it I don't feel bad I don't feel
like I've left some prediction value on
the table that someone else with a
better compression algorithm could have
used that's what it means
and in particular it's like yeah like
you can go and you can sleep happily at
night knowing that if there is some
information in the unlabeled data that
could help my task
no one else like no no one could have
done as good of a job as me I've done
the best job at benefiting from my
unlabeled data
so I think that is a step towards
thinking about unsupervised learning you
don't know if your unsupervised data set
is actually useful it may be super
useful it may have the answer it may be
totally useless it may be the uniform
distribution
but if you have a low regret on
supervised learning algorithm you can
say whether it's the first case or the
second case I know I've done my best I
know I've done my best at benefiting
from my unlabel data
no one could have done better than me
now I want to take a detour to some to
to Theory land which is a little obscure
I think it is interesting
call magorov complexity as the ultimate
compressor gives us the ultimate low
regret algorithm which is actually not
an algorithm because it's not computable
but you'll see what I mean really
quickly so comic books first of all like
for some context who know who here is
familiar with complexity
okay about 50 yeah um it's it's the
Commodore complexity is the kind of
thing which is easy to explain in one
minute
so I'll just do it
it's like
imagine
if I give you some data or you give me
some data and I'm going to compress it
by giving you the shortest program
that can possibly exist the shortest
program that exists which if which if
you run it outputs your data
oh
okay yes
yes that is correct
you got me
it is the length of the shortest program
which outputs X
yes
intuitively
you can see
this compressor
is quite good
because you can prove this theorem which
is also really easy to prove
or rather it's really it's easy to feel
it and once you feel it you could kind
of believe me that it's easy to prove
and you can basically say that you call
magorov compressor
if you use that to compress your strings
you'll have very low regrets about your
compression quality you can prove this
result
it says that if you got your string X
your data set database whatever
the shortest program which output X is
shorter than whatever your compressor
needed output and however value
compressor compress your data Plus
a little term which is however many like
characters of Code you need to implement
your compressor
intuitively you can see how it makes
sense the simulation argument right the
simulation argument if you tell me hey
I've got this really great compressor C
I'm going to say cool does it come with
a computer programmer
can you give this computer program to K
and K is going to run your compressor
because it runs computer programs you
just need to pay for the program links
so without giving you the details I
think I gave you the feel of it
oh my god of complexity the column of
compressor can simulate how the computer
program simulate out the compressors
this is also why it's not computable
it's not computable because it simulates
it feels very much at Liberty to
simulate all computer programs
but it is the best compressor that
exists and we were talking about Good
compression for unsupervised learning
now let us
generalize a common core of complexity a
common growth compressor to be allowed
to use site information
oh more than detailed so I'll make this
detail I'll I'll reiterate this point
several times because this point is
important obviously the Commodore
compressor is not computable
it's undecidable but like hey
because it's like searches overall
programs but hey did you know that if
you're an SGD over the parameters of
some neural net with the hundred layers
it's like
automatically like doing program search
over a computer which has a certain
amount of memory a certain number of
steps it's kind of like
kind of like row
homograph like 59 year old Nets you kind
of see the feel the similarity
it's kind of magical right
neural networks can simulate little
programs they are little computers
they're circuits circuits are computers
Computing machines and SGD searches over
the program
and all of deep learning is changes on
top of the SGD miracle
that we can actually train these
computers with SGD
that works
actually find the circuits from data
therefore we can compute our miniature
Commodore compressor
the simulation argument applies here as
well by the way I just want to mention
this one fact I don't know if you've
ever tried to design a better neural
network architecture what you'd find is
that it's kind of hard to find a better
new network architecture you say well
let's add this connection let's add that
connection and let's like modify this
and that why is it hard the simulation
argument because your new architecture
can be pretty straightforwardly
simulated by old architecture except
when it can't those are rare cases and
in those rare cases you have a big
Improvement such as when you switch from
the little RNN to the Transformer the
RNN has a bottleneck the hidden state
so it's a hard time implementing a
Transformer however had we
found a way to engineer and Ireland with
a very very large Hidden State perhaps
it would become as good as a Transformer
again
so
this is the link you start to see how we
switch from the formal from the formal
land to neural network land but you see
the similarity
so conditional common girl common girl
complexity as the solution to
unsupervised learning
you can basically
have a similar Theory similar theorem
where I'm not going to Define what well
I'm going to Define what K of Y given X
is it's like the shortest program which
outputs y
if it's allowed to probax
that's the length of that shortest
program which outputs y if it allows to
probe X and you can prove the same
result and you can see immediately that
yeah this is definitionally the solution
to unsupervised learning
if you use that you can sleep very very
safely at night soundly at night knowing
that no one doesn't supervise learning
better than you
right
it's literally that so this is the
ultimate
low regret solution to unsupervised
learning except that it's not computable
but I do think it's a useful framework
and here we condition on a data set not
an example
and this thing will extract all the
value for out of X for predicting y the
data set the data set not the example
so this is the solution to unsupervised
learning done
success
and there is one little technicality
which I need to spend a little bit of
time talking about which is
we were talking about this conditional
Commodore of complexity right where you
are talking about compressors that get
to see
try to try to compress one thing while
having access to another thing
and this is a bit unnatural in a machine
learning context when you care about
oh
like fit in big data sets at least as of
today although it's changing fairly
rapidly but I think it's still fair to
say that there is no truly good way of
conditioning on a big data set you can
fit a big data set but you can't
condition it not yet not truly
so this result says that hey if you care
about making predictions about your
supervised task why
using
the good old-fashioned compressor which
just compresses at the concatenation of
X and Y is going to be just as good as
using your conditional compressor
there are more details and a few
subtleties to what I just said
and I'm happy to talk about them offline
in the event someone is interested in
them but that basically says that if
before you're saying hey for previous
slide said
that you can use this conditional
commagorov compressor to solve on
supervised learning
this says that you can also use your
regular chromogorial compressor just
throw all your data take all your files
concatenate them compress them and
that's going to make some great
predictions on your supervised task the
tasks that you care about
there are some intuitions about why this
is true this result is actually like
proving this is slightly more tricky so
I won't do it
and yeah so the solution to unsupervised
learning just give it all to Common Core
complexity to your common core
compressor
okay
and the final thing is I'll mentioned
that this kind of joint compression is
maximum likelihood if you don't overfit
if you have a data set
then the sum of the likelihood given
your parameters is the cost of
compressing the data set you also need
the cost to pay the cost of compressing
the parameters but you can kind of see
if you now want to compress two data
sets no problem just add more points to
your training set to your data set and
add the terms to your to the sump
so this concatenation this joint
compression is very natural in a machine
learning context which is why it was
worth the hassle of saying yeah like we
have our conditional Commodore
complexity and then I made some
arguments I made some claim without
fully defending it but it is possible to
defend it that using regular
just compress everything called
complexity works also
and so I think this is this is elegant I
like it
because then it says well okay
if you squint hard enough you can say
that this explains what our neural
network is doing you can say hey SGD
over big neural networks is our big
program program search bigger neural
networks approximate the common group of
compressor more and more and better and
better
and so maybe this is also why we like
big neural Nets because we approached
the unapproachable idea of the Common
Core of compressor which truly has no
regret and we just want to have less and
less regret as we train larger and
larger as we train larger and larger
neural Nets as far as extracting
predictive value is concerned
now
the way this applies to the GPT models
you know I claim that it applies to the
GPT models also this this Theory but the
thing that's a little bit tricky with
the GPT models is that the theory of
their behavior can also be explained
without making any references to
compression or supervisor you just say
no it's just the conditional
distribution of text on the internet
you should learn and just imagine a
document with some repeating patterns
the pattern is probably going to
continue
so the GPT models can intuitively be
explained at least they're
Fusion Behavior this can definitely be
explained without alluding to this
Theory
and so
you saw I thought it would be nice can
we find some other
direct validation of this Theory
now can we find a different domain like
Vision like because Vision you have
pixels
can you show that doing this on pixels
will lead to good unsupervised learning
an answer is yes you can
this is work we've done in 2020
which is called the igbt and it's an
expensive proof of concept it's not
meant to be it was not meant to be a
practical procedure it meant to be a
paper that showed that if you have
really good Next Step predictor you're
going to do great in supervised learning
and it was proved in the image domain
image domain and there I'll just spell
it out you have your
image
you turn it into a sequence of pixels
each pixel should be given some discrete
value of intensity
and then just do next pixel prediction
be the same Transformer
that's it different from birth
just next token prediction because this
maximizes the likelihood therefore
compressors
and like we see one immediate result we
see this is
these are results on so these are
results on c410 you have different
models of different sizes this is their
next prediction accuracy on their pixel
prediction task when they're on the
supervised learning task and this is
linear probe accuracy linear probe when
you pick some layer inside your neural
net the best layer feed the linear
classifier and see how well it does you
got these nice looking curves and they
start to get more and more similar
kind of what you want it's like it's
working
pixel prediction
of the same variety as next world
prediction next big not just pixel Not
Mere pixel prediction but next pixel
prediction
leads to better
it leads to better and better
unsupervised life
I thought that was pretty cool and we
tried it we scaled it up to various
degrees and we showed that indeed it
learns
reasonably well where we came close but
we didn't like fully match the gap
between our and supervised learning and
the best and supervised learning of the
day on imagenet but it was clearly a mad
it did feel like it scaled and it was a
matter of compute because like you know
these these things use large high
resolution images and we use like tiny
64 by 64 images with giant transformers
fourth day tiny by today's standards but
giant for the day six billion parameters
so it's like yeah you do your
unsupervised next pixel prediction on a
big image data set and then you fit your
linear Probe on imagenet and you get
strong results
like okay that is that is cool
see far yeah like we've got one of the
cool things if you got 99 on c410 with
this
that was cool
I was I was that you know 2020 it was a
different time but
it was cool
I'll mention
I'll close with a couple of comments on
linear representations
you know the thing
the theory because I feel like it just
bothered me for a long time that you
couldn't think rigorously about
unsupervised learning I claim now you
can at least do some partial degree
still lots of waving of hands is needed
but maybe a bit less than before
but it doesn't say why your
representation should be linearly
separable it doesn't save a linear prox
to happen linear linear representations
happen all the time
and the reason for the information must
be deep and profound and I think we
might be able to crisply articulate it
at some point
one thing which I thought was
interesting is that Auto release next
pixel prediction model or regressive
models seem to have better linear
representations than birth
and like the blue the blue accuracies
bird versus Auto aggressive I'm not sure
why that is or rather I can speculate
have some speculations but
it would be nice to
I think it would be nice to get gain
more understanding for why like really
why those linear representations are
formed
and yeah this is the end thank you for
your attention
[Applause]
you provide the speculation yeah oh yeah
yeah I think the speculation is
basically that if you're doing Xbox
prediction
you're predicting the next pixel from
all the previous pixels so you need to
look at the long range structure
but in Bert you have your vector and
let's say you drop 25 percent of the
tokens
of the pixels in this case then any
prediction that you have
can actually be done quite well by
looking a little bit into the past and a
little bit into the future
so you remove you remove all the hard
prediction tasks
well you make them much easier the
hardest prediction task in the next
pixel prediction is a lot harder than
the hardest prediction task in the birth
prediction case so this is an argument
you know we may be even be able to test
it if we think a little if we if you try
to design an experiment to test it but
uh yeah that's a speculation
is there more robust 2D version of the
next next pixel 3G
I would say more robust
I would say any
form of any
anything you do at all that turns a
neural network into a probabilistic
model that assigns probabilities to
different inputs is that
so the other big way of doing
next next token prediction is diffusion
mods
diffusion models also like not the ones
that are so
the the diffusion models that people use
in like high quality image generators
don't really maximize the likelihood of
their input steps they have a different
objective but
the most original formulation
is maximizing likelihood
and by the way the diffusion model is a
counter argument to my to well rather
the diffusion model
also I would claim should have worse
representations
than a next token prediction model
for people for the same reason that bird
doesn't so I feel so this further in my
mind increases the mystery of what
caused leads to linear representations
to form
yes uh yeah thanks for the talk I like
the analogy between cologram complexity
and uh and neural networks I guess one
kind of place where it seems like
there's a disinology is that neural
networks have training Dynamics and you
know if you do something like just take
all the computer program
complexity like the order of the data
doesn't matter it clearly does for
neural Nets you know you have like
simple heuristics and features that I
learned earlier in training that
probably stick around
training
um and so I guess do you have thoughts
on how to think about that in the
context of this picture
yeah I mean the analogy isn't perfect
that is true and the way in which you
describe it's important
the place where the analogy breaks down
the most is in the search procedure
right this is really what you're
alluding to okay like order of data
matters why because we are using a weak
search procedure
Commonwealth compressor uses the
infinitely expensive search procedure of
just enumerate everything from scratch
each time
so yeah I mean it is
I mean
I would say
that caution should be used for this
particular analogy it's not it's very
clearly not universally applicable
but I do think that in the K in I do
think that there is some value here in
explaining where unsupervised learning
comes from
going back and forth between compression
and next prediction you're so uh
unsupervised learning supervised
learning so if you see the backtrack
from crypto photography they're sort of
uh you know it goes back to the 80s
where they talk about compression being
equivalent to an expect prediction being
equivalent to being able to distinguish
so if you have analysis
that can predict
then you have an algorithm that can
I mean photography is the element right
you say there is no way to compress
so I wonder if this idea of being able
to distinguish how could that trans
would that translate to anything
naturally
so
I think I understand I think I
understand the question I think let me
paraphrase so I'm not super well versed
in the area that you that you mentioned
but you're saying if you can distinguish
to distribution you can use that
distinguishability to make some
to predict and I guess the question
would be
what's the ex like
I have some samples from one you have
samples from the other and you can tell
them and so I guess my question is how
well can you predict what you're talking
about you can predict a little bit is
that what you already
you can you can predict what the next
bit would be let's see for example
so
I mean I can mention one thing that is
related which is energy-based
so energy-based models offer yet another
way of turning neural networks into
probability distributions
where energy an energy-based model will
say I just give give me all
configuration of vectors and I'm just
going to tell you how like
how it feels and then you normalize over
all of them and I feel like when it
comes to energy-based models in
particular
ratio like ratios of distributions
correspond to differences of energy
maybe there is some relation to what
you're saying I think I'm probably not
like precisely commenting on the thing
which you said but I don't think I I
have anything more to add unfortunately
oh yeah maybe I'll just put in a tiny
word to defend the honor of VC Dimension
right well so I mean in 2007 I had this
theorem about a pack learning of quantum
States right and this was precisely an
example where even if you don't care
about infinite Precision even if you
discretize the state space like you look
at the BC Dimension or the fat
chattering Dimension or whatever and it
is exponentially smaller than the log of
the size of the hypothesis class so I do
think there are cases where you still
want BC dimensions
that is a cool example
so uh
though your uh
April X was a sample from a distribution
of the distribution data set so then the
Transformer SGD I'm not sure if you can
think of it as the best program for
compressors
maybe because it's only given one
sampler that's true there is one other
assumption that we are making so the
if you
if you look at the if you look at the
total training loss say you have some
neural network doesn't need to be
Transformer some neural network which
assigns log probabilities to your data
you have
some large number of training cases
you can run the neural network and you
have some some neural network you can
compute a slope probability on each case
and you can take it there's some
and that's going to be the log
probability that the neural network
assigns to the entire data set now the
neural network is an a this particular
formulation makes the neural network
unable to explicitly notice like maybe
temporal or any kind of structure in the
order of the data
but in the but I but I still claim it's
meaningful to say that yeah like okay
you can compute the entire log
probability of the data set and that
gives you your
negative log probability literally the
the the number of bits you need to
compress this data etcetera probably
using this neural network as a
compressor
uh you you're arguing for compression as
a framework for understanding or
motivating unsupervised learning and a
point you made at the end was that if
you apply that framework to language
models to next word prediction it can
feel a little maybe superficial because
next word prediction you know any text
task can be converted to an expert
prediction and so unsupialized learning
is kind of superficially the same as
supervised learning for text so then we
turn to image GPT where you can't
formulate
the next pixel prediction maybe you
could but let's just say you can't but
then you can use the linear
representation and that's a way of
showing that compression is a good way
to formulate unsupervised learning but
then
there are highly effective compressors
that wouldn't give you a useful linear
representation so I'm wondering are
there any cases where unsupervised
learning and supervised learning are not
superficially
but that you wouldn't you don't require
your compressor to give you an effective
linear representation to show that
compression is a good unsupervised
objective yes so
that's a very that I I have I have
thoughts on this question
first of all I will say that the linear
representation
a good linear representation is a bonus
at no point does this argument say and
therefore linear representation should
emerge however I would argue that the
theory does say that good fine-tuning
should emerge because joint compression
is kind of like hacky approximate
finding using the bad search algorithm
which is SGD
now we know that
the evidence from from these old
experiments suggests that Bert learns
worse linear representations than next
pixel prediction when run on images
and perhaps the same is true for
diffusion models that seems highly
likely
I think it'll be very interesting to see
how the fine tune your diffusion models
compare maybe someone knows already here
um so uh I wonder if you can take your
ideas for unsupervised learning and
bring them back it seems to me that
there could be some insights you could
take back
well I think here this gives you more
like uh
insight into the so there's a particular
Insight you might get here is inside
into the function class it's our desired
function class like you want your new
relatively layers for example right if
you have many layers it can do more
think anyone is there is to be wider
bigger you know bigger neural Nets I
mean essentially this is like what's
what the field has already discovered
that you might not need more examples
than number and supervised learning is
if you don't need necessarily more
parameters
like that's right so this might for
example be like so there is a so so the
the weakness of this Theory by the way
this theory is a huge practical victims
which is it ignores compute cost it only
focuses on information so like you're
all familiar with the universal
Transformer
maybe it's like basically it's like it's
a Transformer but it's the same way to
each layer
it's a great idea except that if you
want to have a lot of parameters you
need to pay for it a lot with computers
nobody wants to do that it's
you you don't ignore compute costs this
ignores compute costs if you ignore
compute costs it gives you a recipe of
how to proceed
what do you think the importance is of
the auto regressive modeling in
particular of the probability
distribution like you can view virta's
sort of kind of
training right
you can find ways to sample out of it
for example
so
certainly diffusion models can be set up
to be maximum live food models
and so all this theory predicts that
diffusion models should also be
it should be possible to make diffusion
models to do equally great things
perhaps with some constant factors of
because this this is like as the earlier
answer this is not a
a compute sensitive Theory so it's going
to say okay like maybe you need like a
factor of 10 or 15 compute and then
things will be the same between the auto
regressive and diffusion models the
older aggressive model has it's just
simple it's convenient maybe the energy
based model will do even greater things
but from that perspective they're all
the same
it seems like gpt4 may be the best
compressor uh at the moment which
presumably is the largest model out
there as well so on one hand it's able
to compress the better on the other hand
the size of the compressor itself is
increasing
or is it that it's actually not
necessarily the case from the
perspective of the theory called
complexity well I mean what matters is
that the cost of the
like
what you really what you really want is
for the
like
there is there is another place in a way
in which this Theory doesn't quite
correspond to reality because this
series says okay fixed status that you
want to compress it but in the way we
train the GPT models you say okay you
have a big training set and then you
have like a test set which is assumed to
be infinite if the test set is infinite
and then you clear about compressing the
test set then you don't care about the
size of your compressor so long as this
test set size is much larger so I would
say that this is also like I would say
at this analogy where some more careful
thinking
would be useful to get clarity
you get enough to use a validation type
that's independent as long as it's
separate that kind of closes the gap
isn't enough it's a good thing it's a
good thing to do is it true like the
thing is with
I think I think it's it's also
well actually like in the single ebook
case right if you are in a single ebook
case then you can just like you know
read your log probes as you train and
that will be something like your the
model's compression of the data set and
that gives you also a good estimate of
the validation set so in the single lipo
case I think saying that things are
quite similar
uh
followed by eight years
these are compressed strings just like
you showed concatenate two strings
together
the reason we're using the output of the
deeper
yeah my only comment on that is that
gzip is not a very strong compressor of
text
so
I think like it does it does show the
things are possible to some degree but
but all the really meaty stuff happens
when you like squeeze the last bits if
you see what I mean
it seems like if it works like a toy
Jacob brought up curriculum effects and
you know how they appear for neural Nets
but not for you know you don't see it
but a Commodore complexity
um we were just talking at lunch about
like what is the current empirical
situation about like how much do
curriculum effects actually matter and
none of us knew the answer
well it's like
so it's a bit you know I I have a take
on this which is
the easier so we've done so we've done a
lot of work as a field
to make the Transformer like the
architectures that we are using to be
relatively easy to optimize we found
good initializations we found good hyper
parameters we made changes to the
architecture so that training is as easy
as possible the easier is the the more
easy the training optimization problem
is the less susceptible you are the
curriculum effects
and like it's known like for example
people who were training all kinds of
exotic architectures like neural Turing
machines for example
which are like this really complicated
things
and it's super super huge numbers of
heterogeneous layers which are different
and that's and you need to be very very
careful with your curriculum but if you
give it the full data set right away
it'll just fail
Ure
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
myself